[音楽]
th
goo
ん
[音楽]
バッハ
me
[音楽]
しています
過去の動画で本当の霊媒師その霊能力者の方に僕の家に来てもらってちょっと見て
もらったんですけどもとりあえずこの a に何かヤバイのがいますよということを
教えていただいってどうすればいいですかって聞いたところをとりあえずあなたの身を
守るために僕の守護霊をこの人形につけて人形を僕を守ってくれる守護霊として
このように置かせていただくということで置かせていただいてるんですけども東京で
ちょっとしばらく家を外してて帰ってきたら見てもらったら分かると思うんですけど
高齢させてもらってた人形の顔が壊れてました
これ結構なんか笑えない方だと思うんすよね結構強い映像かもしれないんですけども
ご覧ください
見事に顔が真っ二つに割れているっていうすごい落ち方でして
あのちょっといろいろ聞いてみたところですね
この人形終わったものが
いました
どうぞなぜことだと思うので一応誰が知るために
放火させていただいておりますよろしくお願いしますします東京チャー言ってたんです
けどどういう経緯でこれは多くまあこの家に忘れてしまったと思って忘れ物したとはい
忘れ物をしてちょっとダッシュで
鳥に
マコネに戻って
カードをとってまあ裏口から出ようと思って
細い蔓あるですけど個奪った瞬間
背後でパリーンって言っ
とてつもない音が響いたので
見てみたらまあ
併設とこの有様
になってて
ただ僕の記憶としてはまあ確かにこのブシロのフォンタナに
アザってしまったのはジーズ
でそのときに
懲役で落ちてしまった分
って誰だ
9分南海学このまあお人形さんも落としてしまったってもあったり
まああのですね僕も実は何回高騰しますんですよ
でも他の省も落としても見たことあったんですけど
なんか顔が割れるってことがなかったんですよね今までまったくなくて
同じなんですよ僕もを落としたことあるんですけど
割れないですよなぜかですね割れなかったんですけどなぜかこのタイミングでまっ
ちゃったっていう
そうですね結構なみんな甘王としてしまった時ってもうこの店もう9ぐらいの消費者
ですか今確かに僕当たった
ちょん切って本当
こんぐらい月わずかだったんだ本当にあの
コマ
細いそれこの道もで当たるときって結構カーンあたりでみんな確かに揺れないと倒れる
んですよね
僕もここさすがに何回も撮ってるんでホントに何か弾けるような音して何か気づいたん
でまぁ本当には終わったことは終わってしまったのは事実なんで本当にすいませねそれ
は僕がでるんぜ子なんで
しょうがないと思うけどそれだともがく
心配ですと逆にだけど魂込められていたんで髪の毛とか入れて魂入れて守ってもらう
ようなことせたんで的にこの子の何かが降りかからないかって心配
は+それによるこの家の影響とかめっちゃ怖いなと思ってて
今のところ何も大丈夫じゃ何もないですね全然これ自分にしかないと思うけど
怖いんですよね何すごいですね悔い改めてください
i 本当にこの曲まさしまあ
なりますまたやります
いやいやでやるですよねです本当にこれもう実行するか耐えられ
うんそう戦車マジで怖いんですよねこれがもう行ってやることがまぁ今まで守って
くださってたものをこうしてしまったんで何か言っ仮に触れて釣って来ないかとか
僕の身に何か振りかかったら嫌だなと思うんで実際にあのこの人形に魂を込めて
くださったそのねーのー
読者の前卑弥呼様という方にちょっと連絡してどうすればいいのかとか何が起きちゃう
のかというのをちょっと聞いてみようと思います
[音楽]
あそれじゃあの先日ですね動画一緒に撮影させていただいたはず目社長と思うの
もなんですけどもそれがやってもらっありがとうございますまじ巫女さん本人です
あっ女性おっしゃになっておりますありがとうございますね映画てっちゃんちょっと
あの
先日その稚児レオ高齢させていただ言った人形があったと思うんですけどそれが
ちょっとおおおっね他の人に落とされて割れちゃって顔がえええええ
これって何かまずいですかねぇ
した状態ですかねそうでなんか店に置いてあって
完全にはいられないそうですね完全に言われてちょっと修復ができないぐらいの割れ
具合なんですけど
[音楽]
てそのままの袋に入れてば神社特価ですね
に持っていかれてまあお焚き上げしてもらうと良いと思いのぞなるほどあの子自身犠牲
を合わせていたさいって言っ
a
まあのそれ自体もでせそのままあの神宮に持っていかれると追ったのお守りでとかが
あるのであそこに持っていかれるかもしくはもうでがさん直接に言ってあの興じて
もらってたんが来ようっていう形としてもらうといいかも
金玉読みたい
bouvet に代わりになっとったアーちゃんヌードル
いい変えたのでなのでそれ画像から壊れたってことはあなたの方はいてねこんな起きる
八卦だとか
それじゃ花は妹アナアート人形がかぶったようなちゃっあれだろそんな音はれるような
問題や色そう言って彼はれっ
ことはそれだけあなた自身に何か髪が起きる可能性があったんだろうっていうことだと
思ってそのまま放置しておくとちょっとまあよくないよね
ただまま品だとかに守ってくれて ev を遅延されなかったとしていただくと話せ
んじゃにの見えてここ考えていいかな
はい予算あれちゃんがいるのではいま途中よってもよろしくお願いじゃねえさん入って
なかったありがとう
タイヤ止めもですジャブをお勧めいたします
はい失礼致します
[音楽]
ほどなぁそうなんですね主席に思ってたのがそこにおいてあって何回が結構落ちてるん
ですよ人形があって今でも落ちてるんですけどもなんかはれたことがなかったんで
なんかバレないのかなと思ってたんですけど偶然中
割れちゃって目が悪いって言うので魂を込めてもらってたんですけども何か僕に災いが
大きそうだったの男が
身をていして守ってくれて割れてしまったここによって僕のその災いが改正されたって
いう感じらしいです
逆に割ったせいで子供が起こっちゃうとかすごいやだったんでなかったちゃんと
霊能力者の方に聞けてちょっと安心しましたこのことを早めに神社に行ってお別れ
しようと思いますこのまま放置しておくとマジで危ないっていうことを言われていたの
で
102ねそういう魂込められたものに何かがあると不安になっちゃいましたというわけ
守ってくれてありがとう
[音楽]